vice president kamala harris made her
first visit to the southern border since
taking
office harris toured immigration
facilities friday and said the biden
administration is making what she
described as quote
extreme progress in addressing the surge
in migrants from central america
republicans criticized her for not
visiting sooner
and for the timing of her trip ahead of
former president donald trump's visit to
the area next week
christina rafini is at the white house
with the latest christina good morning
good morning dana this trip which white
house officials tell cbs news was
organized very quickly
comes just a few days before former
president trump is
set to take his own tour of the texas
border
more than 90 days after the border
crisis was added to her portfolio
vice president kamala harris arrived in
el paso
i said back in march i was going to come
to the border so this is not a new plan
the long-awaited visit was organized so
quickly white house sources told cbs
news it caused confusion
and left some staffers to learn details
about the trip
including its exact location from media
reports
it is here in el paso that the previous
administration's
child separation policy was unveiled
but republicans criticized the vp for
not going to the rio grande valley
where most border apprehensions take
place and for waiting so long
she avoided traveling to the border for
more than 90 days in that short amount
of time of more than three months
there's been more than half a million
encounters harris said she wanted the
stop to highlight the human side of the
crisis
touring a processing center and meeting
with migrant kids
this issue cannot be reduced to a
political issue
we're talking about children we're
talking about family
and our approach has to be thoughtful
and effective and while the parties
remain on opposite sides of the border
issue
back in washington the bipartisan bridge
building on more than a trillion dollars
in infrastructure projects is now in
doubt
for me investment in our physical and
human infrastructure are inextricably
intertwined
both make us better off and stronger
after president biden said he will only
sign the bill if it coincides with
passage of a much larger budget plan
one democrats want to push through
without republican support
now republican lawmakers who were part
of that deal say that's different than
what the president told them in person
but progressive lawmakers have said
they're not willing to vote for that
scaled down infrastructure bill
unless it coincides with a larger bill
that includes things like human what
they're calling human infrastructure
that's child care free community college
green energy
all those things that were in the
president's original six trillion dollar
bill
that republicans called a non-starter so
round and round we go michelle
sounds like a deal isn't set just yet
christina thank you so much